[Música]
Vladimir Putin visitó Mario Paul en su
primer viaje a territorio ucraniano
ocupado desde el inicio de la invasión
rusa del año pasado y un día después de
estar en crimea para conmemorar los 9
años de anexión de la Península kiev
denunció lo que llamó cinismo por parte
de Putin
el mayor grupo bancario de Suiza vs
comprará a su principal rival Credit
swiss por 3000 millones de dólares Se
resuelven así días de incertidumbre
desde que Credit suiz entró en una
crisis de liquidez a principios de
semana
el fiscal que Investiga Donald Trump en
el caso Story Daniels pidió a su equipo
que no se dejen intimidar por el anuncio
del expresidente que ayer instó a sus
seguidores a protestar y recuperar la
nación si es detenido e imputado por la
justicia
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
abrimos esta edición con una de las
noticias que ha marcado la jornada desde
primera hora de la mañana y es que el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin llegó
este domingo a Mario Paul controlada
Desde los primeros meses de la invasión
rusa por las fuerzas de Moscú tras un
violento asedio se trata de la primera
visita de Putin a una zona ocupada en
esta guerra y tras la visita Mario Paul
la prensa rusa informa que Putin ordenó
acelerar los procesos de nacionalización
rusa de los habitantes de la ciudad los
detalles con amalgman casi como un
desafío a la comunidad internacional dos
días después de que la Corte Penal
Internacional emitiera una orden de
arresto en su contra impidiéndole viajar
a los 123 países que reconocen la
jurisdicción de la corte Vladimir Putin
apareció en Mario Paul la ciudad
portuaria ucraniana zona estra en el mar
de asoff fue escenario de cruentos
combates a principios de la invasión y
también de presuntos crímenes de guerra
que justamente serán investigados por la
cpi
la acusación es que niños fueron
llevados en avión por carretera en tren
a la federación rusa y dados en adopción
que se aprobaron leyes por decreto
presidencial que no se les enseñó en
ucraniano sino en ruso y que fueron
convertidos en ciudadanos rusos
supuestamente parece que esto es
claramente una violación de la cuarta
convención de Ginebra y por eso seguimos
adelante cuando las pruebas nos obligan
a hacerlo
Precisamente en Mario Paul el 16 de
marzo de 2022 un ataque contra un teatro
donde se resguardaban civiles generó
escándalo internacional el hecho de esos
cientos de muertos y más de un año
después fue recordado por los residentes
de Praga
Nosotros hemos dibujado aquí la palabra
niños en ruso solo para reconstruir la
misma situación cuando la gente
intentaba Mostrar al ocupante que eran
civiles que sólo intentaban salvar sus
vidas las autoridades ucranianas
denunciaron lo que calificaron como la
visita del criminal internacional a
maripol un paso que se echó de manera
espontánea según el kremlin tras su
recorrido por la Península de crimea
coincidiendo con el noveno aniversario
de su anexión y este domingo hace
exactamente 20 años una coalición
internacional liderada por Estados
Unidos comenzó a lanzar misiles contra
Irak fue la antesala de la invasión por
tierra del 20 de marzo así empezó una
guerra ilegal basada en pruebas falsas
que marcó la doctrina securitaria y la
geopolítica de estas décadas Catalina
Gómez Ángel nuestra enviada especial a
Bagdad nos cuenta cómo fueron las
primeras horas de este conflicto que
derrocó al fallecido
Sadam hussein
a mis espaldas Al otro lado del río
Tigris estaban los palacios de gobierno
del ex dictador sadampuny también es
allí ese lugar que luego posteriormente
los estadounidenses llamarían como la
zona verde o el famoso Green son de este
fue uno de los primeros lugares que
empezaron a ser atacados el 19 de marzo
de hace 20 años cuando después de meses
de conversaciones discusiones ponencias
en las Naciones Unidas y argumentos de
los norteamericanos que trataban de
convencer al mundo de que Sadam husein
tenía un programa de armas destrucción
masiva ordenaron el ataque a este país
luego tuvieron que reconocer que Estas
armas no existían pero ya estaban dentro
del país causando un terror dentro de la
población que en algún momento algún
sector nos recibió como liberadores pero
muy rápidamente lo señalaron de
ocupantes aquí nos cuenta la población
muchos de los que se quedaron en Bagdad
los que son mayores es que aquel día o
muchos habían sacado a sus familias de
la ciudad o se encerraron en sus casas
durante semanas los norteamericanos
entraron por el sur por la zona de
basura porque allí estaban los grandes
yacimientos de petróleo que querían
asegurar y luego fueron subiendo hasta
llegar hasta aquí hasta la capital de
Bagdad y luego ya menos de un mes
después declararían el final de la
Guerra sin embargo las consecuencias de
esta invasión han se han prolongado en
el tiempo por estos 20 años los iraquíes
han sufrido una guerra tras otra guerra
y esto continuó incluso después de que
los norteamericanos ya se retiraron del
país en el 2011 luego volvieron en el
2014 por invitación del gobierno en la
guerra contra el estado islámico pero el
país sigue sufriendo grandes
consecuencias
a uno y cuando la seguridad ha mejorado
y los iraquíes especialmente en Bagdad
han vuelto a disfrutar por lo menos de
lo que es la vida pública
y Recuerden que mañana lunes 20 de marzo
el motivo de los 20 años del inicio de
la guerra en Irak en France 24 les
ofrecemos una programación especial en
la emisión matinal de directo a América
de 7 a 9 de la mañana hora de Bogotá
quito y Lima
en Egipto en presencia de oficiales de
Estados Unidos y Jordania representantes
del gobierno de Israel y de la autoridad
Palestina llegaron a un acuerdo para
intentar detener la violencia armada de
cara al mes sagrado del ramadán que
empieza el jueves sin embargo la mayoría
de organizaciones palestinas entre ellas
jamás rechazan los diálogos porque
acusan a Israel de incumplirlos y
usarlos de tapadera mientras aumenta la
violencia mortal que ejercen sus redadas
en los territorios ocupados recordemos
que en lo que va de año las fuerzas
israelíes han matado 86 palestinos
mientras Trece israelíes han muerto a
manos de palestinos según la agencia afp
el gobierno británico Avanza en su
política contra la inmigración irregular
recordemos que El Ejecutivo de Richie
sunat presentó un plan que impediría
solicitar asilo a las personas que
lleguen a Reino Unido cruzando el Canal
de la Mancha una medida que atenta
contra el derecho internacional al asilo
por otro lado Londres Avanza en su plan
de las deportaciones a Ruanda y la
ministra del interior está en kigali
precisamente para agilizar su política
de enviar al país africano a las
personas que lleguen sin papeles a
territorio británico una medida que
hasta el momento ha sido detenida por la
justicia Europea
Vimos a fines del año pasado personas
que morían en el canal en su fallo
intento por llegar al Reino Unido
Entonces lo compasivo lo humanitario que
se debe hacer es encontrar otra solución
y es por eso que creo como acaba de
decir el ministro Que aquí hay una
oportunidad real de reubicar a las
personas
en entornos seguros y protegidos donde
puedan llevar una vida próspera y
saludable y por eso estoy muy
entusiasmada con este acuerdo que creo
que será un modelo para otros países en
el futuro
y pasamos a Francia Porque mientras en
las calles la indignación con el
gobierno francés se expresa en forma de
protestas y huelgas en la asamblea
nacional este lunes se votará una moción
de censura en contra del ejecutivo de
Elizabeth born Esta es una de las
últimas opciones para tumbar la
impopular reforma de las pensiones
impuesta por Emanuel macron Sin embargo
a esta hora es poco probable que la
moción de mañana cuente con el apoyo de
la mayoría de parlamentarios
el lunes marcará un momento decisivo
para Francia con lo que ocurra en la
asamblea nacional para final de jornada
sabremos si la controversial reforma
pensional fue aprobada o no el escándalo
de estalló en la cámara del pasado
jueves cuando la primera ministra activó
el artículo 49.3 de la Constitución para
evitar un voto en la asamblea dos
mociones de censura fueron presentadas
en consecuencia una por parte de la
agrupación nacional que tiene pocas
posibilidades de aprobarse la otra a
manos de un grupo de partidos de
oposición para recibir la luz verde una
moción de censura necesita 287 votos la
bancada presidencial cuenta con 250
mientras que la oposición con 257 lo que
significa que con 61 votos necesarios
todas las miradas se posan sobre el
partido de derecha los republicanos
la líder del grupo parlamentario de
macron defendió la necesidad de una
reforma pensional si esta reforma no
existe todos aquellos que ustedes
mencionan aquellos que están en línea de
frente con los pagos más bajos serán
aquellos que resultarán más golpeados no
somos los que estamos en esta mesa los
preocupados por el futuro de nuestras
pensiones por ahora solo unos cuantos
parlamentarios de los republicanos han
dicho que votarán en contra del gobierno
pero el partido Francia en sumisa
mantiene las esperanzas de recibir el
apoyo
saben también como yo que el gobierno
está al borde del colapso y son los
republicanos los que quedaron ante la
espada y la pared porque ellos tendrán
la última palabra y nos queda esperar
que para un partido que reivindica la
herencia de de Gol dirán es suficiente
estamos en contra de esto las mociones
de censura tienen pocas opciones de
prosperar en tal caso el siguiente paso
para la reforma sería un llamado por
parte de grupos opositores para que el
consejo constitucional Determine si la
legislación es acorde con la Carta Magna
Incluso si la ley es aprobada la primera
ministra quedará en una posición frágil
y su gobierno se enfrenta a un futuro
incierto en lo que al presidente
respecta no está claro Cuándo se
dirigirá al pueblo en momentos de Gran
crisis política y social
y seguimos en Europa porque tras semanas
de incertidumbre y de temor de que se
desatara una crisis bancaria a escala
global finalmente los problemas de
liquidez de créditos se resolverán con
la compra de la entidad Por parte de su
principal rival vs de este modo el
primer grupo bancario de Suiza comprará
el segundo por un valor de 3.000
millones de dólares el presidente del
Banco Nacional de Suiza aseguró que este
es un acuerdo necesario para evitar las
turbulencias dada la frágil situación
del mercado en la actualidad
bajo estas condiciones el Consejo
Federal está convencido de que esta
difícil situación la adquisición de
parte de vs es la mejor solución para
restaurar la confianza que ha estado
faltando en los mercados financieros en
los últimos tiempos y controlar mejor el
riesgo para nuestro país y nuestra gente
pasamos al continente americano porque
hay nueva reacciones al anuncio del
expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump quien ayer publicó en su red
social que según una filtración sería
arrestado el martes por lo que animó a
sus seguidores a defenderlo y a retomar
la nación Trump recordemos está
investigado por el presunto uso de
fondos de su campaña de 2016 para pagar
por el silencio de la actriz porno Storm
y Daniels de ser acusado formalmente se
convertiría en el primer presidente
estadounidense en enfrentar un proceso
penal precisamente el fiscal que lleva
el caso envió un mensaje de calma a su
equipo al que tuvo acceso el medio de
comunicación político
tenemos plena confianza en nuestro
destacado personal de seguridad e
investigadores junto con nuestros
excelentes colegas de la oficina
administrativa de la corte y la policía
de Nueva York y continuaremos
coordinándonos con todos ellos no
toleraremos los intentos de intimidar a
nuestra oficina o amenazar el estado de
derecho en Nueva York y previamente
hablamos con Rafael peñalver analista
político y abogado en derecho
constitucional de Estados Unidos quien
nos analizó el escenario actual
lo que se le podría acusar en todos
estos desde luego es especulativo porque
todo lo que se presenta ante un gran
Jurado es secreto pero lo que se
especula es que se le pueda encausar por
falsificación de documentos y son que es
un delito de menor cuantía en el estado
de Nueva York si uno combina un delito
de menor cuantía para tratar de tapar
algo que pueda llegar a otro delito de
mayor cuantía Entonces ahí es donde
surge el la base del encauzamiento algo
difícil algo que sería para Estados
Unidos comenzar un proceso que nunca
había como tú bien dices nunca se han
causado a un expresidente y hacerlo por
una razón de este tipo cuando hay otros
otras investigaciones muchos más serias
pendientes por el intento de de parar la
el traspaso Pacífico de la presidencia
en el año 2020 Eso hace que muchas
personas cuestionen la sabiduría de
traer estos cargos en estos momentos y
si Ramos esta edición con imágenes de
las fallas en Valencia España una
festividad centenaria alrededor del
fuego y la sátira durante todo el año
los artesanos falleros crean inmensas
figuras que pueden llegar hasta los 30
metros de alto muñecos que hacen
referencia a la actualidad política y
social y que son quemados en medio de
pirotecnia y música tradicional una
celebración que en 2016 la UNESCO
inscribió en el patrimonio inmaterial de
la humanidad
[Música]
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
pero sigan con más información en 24 y
34 punto com
[Música]